welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the batman with robert
pattinson revealed some major easter
eggs from production
a film that still has me freaking pumped
despite its delay to march 2022
that's how hard pattinson's punches land
folks what is this movie coming out
all four digits our question marks now
i'm gonna break down the new details we
just learned because while some may be
scrutinizing pattinson for covet
symptoms or muscle mass
i look at these images and say i want
that purple stuff oswald cobblepot shirt
is purple his car is purple purple is a
flavor and i love it
spoiler warning in case you don't want
to see any of this stuff but i am
telling you you are going to want some
news to keep your appetite
wet between now and the year what when
oh okay at the moment production for
matt reeves the batman has resumed in
the uk
most recently at liverpool's st george
hall before it is scheduled to move on
to chicago now the scene we are looking
at here is the exterior of a funeral
that of the late mayor don mitchell jr
whom we saw in the trailer was murdered
by the riddler edward nashton
shortly after mitchell won re-election
for a historic third term
these new images depict pattinson as
bruce wayne colin farrell
in sure to be oscar winning makeup as
oswald cobblepot penguin
john chituro as crime boss carmine
falcone and zoe kravitz as a
dapper celina kyle now if you remember
the trailer showed the inside of
mitchell's funeral in that church
getting
crashed literally by an suv driven by
another riddler victim looks like
district attorney gil coulson peter
sarsgaard's character
strapped with a neck bomb and another
riddle and then batman shows up later
but gets caught and sars guards boom
boom but it's the images of selena kyle
beside carmine falcone that are the most
interesting to me
she is linking arms with him and if you
look closely at his face you can see a
scar
on his right cheek similar scarring
appears on the right cheek of
oswald whose umbrella tip looks a little
too
sharp and blood stain for comfort so
what does all this mean for the plot of
the batman based on everything else we
know about this movie well before i
continue i want to thank our friends ed
bessie for sponsoring this video bessie
makes these awesome knit sneakers that
are 100
waterproof and weatherproof they are
super breathable too so they don't let
any liquid
in but they do let the air move out they
also have this antimicrobial insole to
keep your footsy woodsy smelly freshy
weshees bessie shoes are also
super stretchy so stretchy
they fit like a sock and they only weigh
175 grams which is the same as 175
paperclips which are not
nearly as comfortable to wear on your
feet they are also made of this cool
dynamex material that keeps your feet
warm in cold weather but helps heat
escape during those steamy months
like winter in la is the one wet season
we have so i love these shoes we're
running errands around town
keeping my feet dry warm and comfy so
i'd like to take a dip in our apartment
pool but i'm not allowed to these days
still my little piggies want a nice
taste of water oh too bad because thanks
to these messy shoes my little piggies
are bone dry and can't feel a thing
get 25 off your own pair of vesty shoes
when you use my link in the video's
description click that link for 25
off of these cool weatherproof knit
sneakers thanks bessie
okay for many the image of selena kyle
on the arm of carmine falcone
looks like a possible clue hinting at
the long-held fan theory from batman
comic raiders that
selena kyle could be the illegitimate
daughter of carmine falcone
that relationship was hinted by the 1999
dark victory storyline but was later
overruled when selena's father was later
established as rex calabrese still
the arkham games did make selena
carmine's daughter many fans continue to
prefer that version
selena being carmine's daughter is an
interesting theory
because clearly selena partners up with
batman in this plot you know breaking
back into the crime scene for the
mayor's residence to retrieve
something from his safe and another
footage appearing alongside
batman on romantic graveyard motorcycle
skids balcony and cobblepot meanwhile
are interesting figures
to see attending the mayor's funeral
because they're you know
criminals it's worth noting though that
on the mayor's wall
was a framed headline crediting the
mayor for a
bust of the moroni crime family the
moroni being another gang in gotham city
who are rivals with the falcones
so by busting up the moroni's the mayor
did a huge favor for carmine it's
looking increasingly likely that the
reason he did that was so that his
historic re-election could be won
delivered to him
rigged by uncle carmine now if selena is
carmine's kid
she would be working against her own
family's interests similar to the
holiday killer in the long halloween who
targeted mafia figures
and was revealed to be spoiler here
carmine falcone's thought to be dead son
alberto valconi but all this doesn't
necessarily mean that selena is
carmine's daughter she could just be his
date
yeah a little young for him but he is
carmine falcone i'm sure his target age
is half his age minus seven but we gotta
talk about the facial scarring on
falcone and cobblepot it could also
be a nod to batman year one in which
catwoman tries to rob falcone and
scratch his scars
into his face with her metal claws scars
that would go on to become a key part of
his identity
similar to the facial scarring of al
capone in the real world zoe kravitz did
say
that she read batman year one
specifically to prepare for her role as
selena kyle in this movie one theory i
put out there is that the city leaders
of gotham are in a conspiracy with the
criminal forces of the city on one side
he got mayor mitchell the d.a
maybe also the police commissioner and
they got secret back channels
working in cahoots with carmine falcone
and his partner oswald coppelpot who i'm
thinking could be running
distribution i have also speculated that
this conspiracy could be under the
wing of the courts of owls the shadowy
cabal that secretly runs gotham city
based on a number of owl clues in this
trailer footage go check out those
videos
and so here we got edward nashton the
riddler a guy who i think
is aware of this conspiracy connection
and that is why he is killing off these
city leaders one by one
and scolding them calling them liars but
i think selena kyle is working to bring
down this power structure from the
inside ephem batol not only is she
wearing a dress hat here she is wearing
a wig
you could say that she is in her own
broad daylight masquerade
posing as carmine falcone's arm candy
but really just trying to get close to
him so that she can dig up her own dirt
on his elite network
that is why she's breaking back into
mitchell's residence and
maybe some of her nighttime jellicle
ball stalking led to scuffles with
falcone and with copperpot with selena
scarring in their right cheeks
marking their guilt for all to see one
idea i've always liked is that selena
could be seeking her own vengeance for
falcone and cobblepot's gang killing her
girlfriend maybe she has a relationship
with bella rayal
mitchell's defeated political opponent
for mayor vengeance is going to play a
big part i think because the movie's
working title is vengeance
and we know it's a motivation she'd have
in common with batman
i'm vengeance also visible in the scene
are protesters bearing the same question
mark symbol as the riddler with signs
reading
our day of judgment and lies lies lies
suggesting the riddler murdering these
people leaving clues behind has kind of
started a movement i just think like any
great war story the investigator may end
up having a lot in common with the
person he's investigating and the femme
fatale is also part of it and as he goes
deeper and deeper into the investigation
he learns his hands are dirty as well
maybe with the wayne family history
involved with the court of owls maybe he
being unwittingly the court of owl's
talon executioner with the real bad guys
being the
old krusty dudes who are playing
everyone against each other i'm gonna
pose this question to you how do you
think selena kyle and the riddler are
gonna be involved in this plot comment
down below discuss
all things nerdy with me on new
rockstar's official discord server by
becoming a patron at
patreon.comrockstars
subscribe to rockstars hit that
notification bell follow me on
instagram at eavos follow me rockstars
thank you for watching batman
[Music]
you